nous entendons également développer
encore les tests de dépistage ceux ci
sont en constante augmentation et le
point le plus positif c'est que leur
résultat quand ils sont pratiqués
demeurent très largement favorables et
en tout cas les tests positifs sont très
nettement inférieur à ce que aux
modélisations qui avait été réalisée au
mois de mai ce qui témoigne sans doute
de l'efficacité de la politique conduite
mais le nombre de tests demeure
insuffisant et s'est expliquée par la
considération précédente
non je le dis au sénat que nous
manquions d'équipement et de personnel
pour les réaliser notamment depuis que
les techniciens de laboratoire ont été
autorisés à effectuer les prélèvements
mais tout simplement parce que nos
concitoyens ne se forme pas suffisamment
testés
ils sont et ils sont sensibles à
l'ambiance générale où l'on dit où l'on
dit que l'épidémie est maîtrisé ce
qu'est le cas il faut donc lever tous
les obstacles y compris psychologique
qui explique cette situation
le président de la république a ainsi
annoncé la fin des prescriptions
médicales obligatoires pour se faire
tester et j'ai par ailleurs demandé est
ce que nous accélérions l'évaluation de
la fiabilité scientifique des tests
salivaires beaucoup plus simple à
réaliser beaucoup moins douloureux et il
nous faudra par ailleurs continuer à
intensifier les actions proactives
invitant les habitants de certaines
communes de certains quartiers à
réaliser des tests ce que nous avons
déjà commencé depuis plusieurs semaines
à faire notamment en ile de france avec
une efficacité certaine
[Musique]